集まったのは多分できないから
とにかくパンデミックのパンデミックで始まって
今だんだん大きくなっているこのグループに
でもあんまり楽器が弾ける人いないよね
でも今年が少し増えるかな
今年が12になった
でも最後に1,000になる
1番目は6人だった
ピアノ、チェイノ、バイオリン、コンテスピナと
それからソプラノ1人
でも今年が
けいこさんも上手よね
バイオリン2人
ケイコさんとも
それからフルト2人
それからセイド
この間の時に見た方ね
ソプラノ3人
ソプラノ1人
4人だった
彼女たちは絶対大変
なんでかというと3年間でみんな
人生変わっている
本当?
そうね
例えば
えっと
ミオさんね
結婚しました
ピアノリストの
マサコさんも
結婚して
子供がいます
みんな
先日が半年
だんだん
聖書しない
って言うじゃない?
そうね
今ね
今
晴れ咲く神様に
会ったりしてるのよね
そう
だから
みんな
こういう
聖書で
人生が
とても喜んでいます
そうね
竹下さんも
あの
ルイスのおかげで
すっかりお友達になって
ルイスがいないときも車で送ってあげてるの
そうね
ちょっとこんな感覚しながらそんなに
遠くないですよね。
サプリセンターからだと、内側だとちょっと多いんだけど
中井いつも送ってあげて
ミキちゃんは何年もかけてないね。
全然来てね。
ミキちゃんは私がいた。
でもまだ半年にならないよね。
ヤツコさんが元に行ったんですか?
ミキちゃんは日本には来てないですけど。
何年前だっけ?
いつだったのね。みんなで行ってしまった。
ミキちゃんは今はグリーンカードを取っているメリカードを取っている。
ミキちゃんはどう取ったの?
ミキちゃんはもうダメだと思うのよ。
ミキちゃんは6月で丸1年経ってあったからね。
ミキちゃんはもう一度やり直さなきゃダメだって書いてある。
ミキちゃんは本当に?
ミキちゃんはやっぱり同じくらい待つでしょって書いてあるの。
ミキちゃんは今、ビザをルイスがたくさん取ってくださったからね。
ミキちゃんはビザがあるから。
ミキちゃんはもう本当に私長くいないと思うから。
ミキちゃんはもうそろそろ天国行っちゃうんじゃないかって。
ミキちゃんは天国行けないでいつまでも途中でふさっかってどうしよう。
どうしよう。
私の方が最近はもうちょっと私はできないとかいうのかな。本当はそうなのよ。
80代じゃ。
毎年やっぱり一人で全部アレンジしてアメリカ行かれるの?
飛行機撮ったりとか、行くまでは大変なの。飛行機に乗るまでが。
もちろん荷物もあるし、だからもう最後よってこの人に。
時期には言わなかった、この人に。
大使がそんなこと言わないで、俺のアメリカに住んで、最後に歓迎して、
人もいろいろ言ってくれる。大使がすごく言ってくれました。
雨は全然、何でも言わない。
「バイバイ」とか言って。
「でも、日本にたって続いて、バレを鳴らしてたのね」
「日本で、日本で、そのオプリンカーを毎週、一人でやって、
車で、一人で待ってなきゃ、あれになってた。
それ、続けてたの?」「続けてるの?」
「バレは、ちょっと、プラダンスをやってるのね」
「なんかね、ダンスがあるのね」
「その、バレは、何やってるの?」
「オプラに、なんてよ、普通の人も、
日本では、出たのよ」
「バレの、バレ」
「あれ、どこでやったんだっけ、あの、舞台でやったときは?」
「どん?」
「日本で、日本で、アメリカ」
「日本で?」
「うん、ルイさん、いなかったのよなぜか、それで、あの、ミッキちゃんが、アメリカを連れてって、あの、
着替えさせたりする、うてつとって、それを、私と一人で、座ってたの。それで、
よろしく~
お客様とかされたってね
もう分からないわけ
どこにいるのか
誰が先に見つけるかとか言って
分からないで
2プロフェッショナル
本当
その後アンミねやっぱりこう目とかあんな綺麗なあんな素敵な目なのにただでたいそれなのにお化粧してねもっとあの綺麗に綺麗にもっとなろうと思ったのかさでミキに怒られちゃったのまだダメだってまだお化粧なんかしたいって普段はいけませんとか言われて
しなくたってあんなに綺麗なんだからそうやね若いけどね
ハニカだからさすごくかわいいのよ
リキもよ本当かっこいいからね
リキももう何年も会ってないね
リキも今3人の一番性が高いのちょっとだけどね
リキも一生懸命勉強しててすごく大変なねあのなんかなんかなんか中の大学って大変なのね
ステイツユニラシティっていうのはちょっとそこへ入っちゃったんですよ
入ったんですよ入ったすごいな
いくつも多かった
アミって同じところも多かったんだけどね
でも結局そのステイツの方に入っちゃったから大変なの
下昇も高いしちょっと今ちょっと大変なの
でも一生懸命勉強してて随分できる
あの今全然困ってないみたいな
最初はなんかあの宿題とかね
最近は何だかわからないぐらいだって言ってたの
今もう全然なのよ
最近だけお家に今帰ってるでしょ
話した電話で
うんそうそう昨日
この間ね帰ってきたのよね
昨日
ああそうかいいな
今
うん
冬休み
でもそれないといけんとこでいいの?
もうちょっと寮じゃなきゃいけないのよアメリカ大学って
そうなの?
うん大体のところがそうなの
うん
アミもよ
そう
だからミキちゃん一人だからね
だから私2ヶ月もいたんだけど
うん
お前だろう
でもミキも忙しくって
私はいつも俺その
俺その番ばっかりなのって
ミキミキさんも全然いないんだもんってね
うん
ミキは何でしょうし
もうアミたられることしてるの?
なんか商売も始めちゃったし
うん
すごいね
キリコさんとかに
タカゴさんか
たかこさんに使われてるのよね、なんだかね。
ちょっとあんまりやりすぎなくてもいいのにってよく言うんだけど。
でも一回私も会ったのね、そのたかこさんっていう方。
それで思ってたよりずっとなんていうか、感じが良かった。
もっと怖い人かと思ったら、ちょっと少し見て、会ったら全然違ってびっくりして。
そうかと思ってたらやっぱりミキさんがね、一緒にいろいろやってるんだなっていう気がする。
お家に来たのよ、みんな。時々やるでしょ、お花だ、お花の時。
おめでとうございます。
私はね、10本ぐらいで電話。
でも、一緒に行って。
でも、待っててもいいわよ。
私は、私たちがもう取り付けられている。
私たちがもう取り付けられている。
ん
飲み出すと飲まないとやっぱり寝られなくなっちゃう
本当に良くない
夜中に目覚めちゃおう?
ちょっとあと寝られないのよね
メメなんて、大気もそうだって言うんだけど
なんか
CDでね、自動的に電気がちゃんと切れるのもあるのね、プレイヤーが
それをCDを結構ガンガンかけて
それで明るくしてあって
あの廊下の方の電気がつけてあって
メメも真っ暗でも静かっていう風に狙わせないの
それ、さっきさんもそうだって言うから
ガンガンガンを見つけた
そっか
リスカ、ハワイに行った時に
なんか、あの
ハワイじゃないか
あの
ウチだったかもしれない
どこだか忘れてたんだけど
大気がそこに寝てるの
5番町かもしれない
上が5番町にいた頃に
大気のお部屋がなかったんだよね
かわいと
みんなが食事したまんまそこで
わわわ
騒いでる時に大気だけもう
お休みとか言って
寝られないそうだったんだけど
しばらくしてよく寝ちゃったのね
それでやっぱりそういう風に
うるさくて明るい方が寝られるっていうのよ
それ、メメそれよく分かるの?
メメってそうなのよ
変でしょ
うるさくなったの?
うるさくなったら
車で一番寝やすいかな
うん
ダメですね
なんか動いてる
そう
5番町にちょっといたもんね
アリシアもいたのよね
うん
よく覚えてる
いつもアリシアに会った?
あの
最近というか
全然
もう4年
今後
何か
ホットフローリーじゃん
出られなかったみたいな
うん
毎年
スピード
はい
2人もいるんだっけ
1人?
面白いよく知らないけど
すごいです
アミとタイキがエコエに入った時に
いろんな先生がいらっしゃって
1人の先生だけがアリシアみたいに
アフリカのカーだったのね
タイキもアミもその先生が一番好きでね
先生とっても不思議があってね
その子たちは自分が来てくれるんだって
私に好きになったって
そうよね
だからやっぱり小さい時からそういうの見てるのって
すごくいいと思う
リキちゃんだってそうよね
小さい時からいろいろんな日本人
アジア人の顔してる人とかいろんな人がいて
それ不思議じゃないじゃない?
だけど
メメンなんてやっぱりずっと
日本人しか見てなかったからね
変なさは思えなかったけど
まあそうした
コリウムも
フランクで学校行ってたことに
あったり
最初にフランクに住まって
生まれたから外国人っていうのも
知らなかったから
新婦様やっぱり
新婦様はドイツ人の新婦様とか
だったのね
精神です
野間田さん
ああそうな
精神の人
英語はちゃんとした
アイリシューとか
ね
どなたは知ってらっしゃる?
今いらっしゃるんでしょう
そうなんでしょ
いっぱい言われたけど
まだ吉川とか覚えてる?
あ、その
学校行ってたじゃないけど
校長さんもだったから
怖い
怖いまだ吉川
その時いらっしゃった
クエンティっていう
クエンティだった方ね
あの方はすごく私が好きで
私がね
こっちがね
すごく好きで
だけど英語ばっかり以上
話してくださるから
それは嫌で逃げてたのよ
分かんないから
困ってそれ
だけどあの
アメリカに
ニューヨークに行ってからね
長いお手紙書いたの
すごく喜んで
すごい長い返事くださって
オスエリアにいらっしゃってたの
そうなんで
全然
それじゃだけど自分はアイリスで、イントンさんはまだシェルドンって言うか、お世話だったんだ。
お世話だったんだ。
だから、レベルはまだ前やって、トイトニー。
あ、そうじゃない。
あ、そうですか。
これとか思って。
まだ長居と。
あの、えっと、お前後さんが今、トイトニーさんが一緒なのよ。
あ、そう?
長居さんって言うんだけどね。
あ、そうなの?
そうやって、バラセータバタできだなってね。
その方、私で2年くらい若いと思う。だけど、ずっとやっぱり嬉しいんだったみたいな。
うんうんうん。
まだ福岡とか。
あ、面白いね。
うん。
そう、だから、リキちゃんたちなんて、人が、フランス語だったら少し困るかもしれないけど、
人言語とか、何かでちょっと分かる言葉で話してきても、全然困らないじゃない。
もう、自分らしいよ。ちゃんと自分はいるからだけど、
メンバーなんて、やっぱり英語で話されると、すごく、すごい困って、いつも逃げ回ってたの。
うん。
まあ、いや、ちょっと、早く言っちゃって。
なんていらっしゃらないわね。お手紙書きたいんだけど。もう。
全然聞かないもんね。そうね。
でも私もフランスであの、おつとめしてた頃に書いたのよ。お手紙。それで返事してくださって。
でもどう言ったって、もう何年?40年くらい。大事なんだ。
私は老朽生だって、もう全部。94だからね。
それも。あと、あと、スラファイルの。
どなたかのおばさまとか、まだ長見ね。
面白い。日本人なんだけど、私たちは老朽生のおばさまとか。
そういう方が何人かいたわね。
すごい。俺になりましたもんね。
もう真っ暗と。
やっぱり。
一番短いって
今日から明日はね
そうか
一番暗いからね
なってなってね
終わったらまだね
一番暗くて
8時半もある
そうよね
2時頃まで明るいの
夏は反対なのね
もう4時ぐらいになる
もう3時ぐらいからね
そうね
イギリスだった頃は
飲んだけど
まだね
寝てきちゃかったけどさ
暗くなってくれ帰ってくるんだから
本当ですか
ねえこうちゃん本当に立派に同じになっちゃった
もう
大変に満ちちゃったんだもんね
本当すごいね
でもこの間の話をもった
あきこさんに聞けようか
なんか世界一周でもないけど
どっか旅行してらっしゃったでしょ
あきこさんと2人で
知らない?
私その話をあきこさんに聞けなきゃと思ってたの
どこ行ったんだよ
なんかいろんなとこ行った
ミッキーにもアメリカから電話
同じアメリカの中で電話かかってきたって言ってた
うん
一つおくらは?
えっと一つおくらは?
今日、あれ?
今年の始めか?去年の終わりか?
まだ1年経ってないと思う
今もう12月だからね
そうね
あ、何?
どうぞどうぞ
それをちょっと見ていきましょう